- That's good, I was planning
on shitting my brains out.
- Oh!
- I knew it.
I knew when you said it
- Called it! Called it!
- So big.
- This is so heavy.
- You can injure someone with this,
isn't this heavy?
- This is a weapon. This is a
weapon of mass destruction.
- Doing some curls.
- This is the world's largest gummy bear.
- Are you going to make us eat this?
- There's 51 servings.
- There's 51 servings
of gummy bears in here.
(laughs)
- This looks like it
contains the soul of a child.
Remember me.
- Oh my God, no it really smells
like that really gross cough
medicine you get as a child.
(smooching)
- It doesn't feel like
a normal gummy bear.
It's much more...
- It feels like silicon.
(rubber twisting)
- Are you going for the head
first or the butt first?
(groans)
- Oh my God.
- I just started with the ear.
I think that'll be an easier way to
munch through.
- Uh.
- Yup, that was a bad idea.
- I can almost hear it
screaming right now.
- I honestly don't feel bad though.
Like, he deserves this.
- Ah, I hurt my jaw.
Workmans comp
for gummy bear injuries.
- It's so thick. (laughs)
- It's so thick.
This is a thick-ass bitch.
- I guess I'll bite it's crotch.
- Yeah do it.
Oh God. (laughs)
- I just want to love him and care for him
(laughs)
- After you've mauled its face?
- Yeah I feel like a monster.
I'm so sorry.
I just want to rub it's tummy.
- Oh my God is this going
to change my poop into blue?
Like, I really hope
- I'm just imagining
you go to poop and it's like
the little actual gummy bears
instead of the big one.
(laughs)
- It tastes like pain.
Like, numbness.
- Honestly it could be anything right now.
- I really could just be
eating flesh right now
cause it has that
consistency aesthetically.
- (laughs) Have you tried flesh?
(laughs)
- I guess we'll never know.
- This is not real food,
this is
something the government made
to put children to death.
- So gummy bears are now
a government conspiracy.
(growls)
- Oh God,
what have I become.
- I feel like the gummy bears.
- He's won.
- I don't think I ever want
to eat gummies ever again.
- My mouth is stained with
the blood of my enemies.
Let this be a warning.
(laughs)
- It like slides down your whole body
and probably out your
butt hole right away.
(laughs)
(splats)
- High-five.